the city of las vegas and the las vegas  1013 club hosted a september 11th  remembrance here at home at the police  memorial park today the ceremony paid  tribute to fallen law enforcement  officers here in our community the las  vegas 10-13 club is comprised of retired  new york city police officers and  retired officers from other police  agencies  i grew up in new jersey so i was close  by i remember where i was as most  military members do  the younger generation many of the boy  scouts and the cub scouts that were here  today weren't even born then  they're the ones that need to carry on  that memory  the group has hosted a remembrance event  every year since 2001.